[Music]
we love a good fan theory and this
tumbler theory is blowing our minds
it's Disney's Moana really just the
Little Mermaid in Reverse stay tuned to
hear all about this theory are you a
Disney fanatic like we are click
subscribe for more amazing videos all
about Disney and more now let's check
out this Moana and Little Mermaid Theory
this crazy fan theory covers the whole
plot of both Moana in the Little Mermaid
in case it's been a while since you've
seen them let's take a look at what each
movie was all about mulana in 2016
Disney release Moana and it instantly
became a huge hit with a fierce new
princess a hilarious demigod and one
amazing soundtrack Moana might be one of
the greatest disney movies ever the
movie starts with an explanation of the
history of the Pacific Islanders at
least the Disney version of the history
a goddess named tip fede created all the
life of the islands then she fell asleep
and became an island herself the demigod
Maui stole two fetus heart and had to
confront a giant lava monster called
taka but Maui got away and the heart was
lost because the heart was stolen the
Islanders were cursed that's pretty
messed up considering it wasn't their
fault a thousand years later we see a
toddler version of Moana she finds two
fetus heart which tries to lead her into
the sea but her dad the chief of their
Island is terrified of the sea he lost
his best friend years ago at sea so he
doesn't let his village go explore so he
pulls Milano away but mallanna's people
have always been sea explorers she feels
like the sea is where she belongs
bow on his father tui is training Moana
to be the next chief but that's not
where her heart is Lana's grandmother
tells her about the curse and gives
Moana tip feed ease heart to Dedes curse
reaches mo Ana's Island and all of the
fish start dying the people are going to
starve but - we will not allow them to
go out further into the sea mo Ana's
grandmother passes away and the last
thing she tells Moana is to go out and
save their people
Moana steals a boat and along with her
dumb chicken hey hey sets out to stop
the curse the ocean leads Moana to a
small island where Maui the thieving
demigod lives she tries to convince him
to help her return the heart
he's too scared but the ocean keeps
putting mallanna in his way until he
agrees to help her they encounter
pirates and they have to descend into
the realm of monsters so Maui can get
his magical fish hook it's held by a
giant man-eating crab named Tama Toa the
crab is evil but he's all erious and he
loves talking about himself now he
teaches Moana how to sail and she helps
him regain his ability to shape-shift
but they fight and get discouraged the
ocean leads Moana to Judy's island where
she's confronted by takeoff she wants to
return the heart and she realizes the
lava monster is actually too fitti
without her heart
Moana returns the heart and to fede
lifts the curse Moana returns her people
and becomes the new chief she leads her
people to become seafaring explorers
again like they were meant to be
beautiful caves she's gonna love it
The Little Mermaid 27 years before Moana
Disney released the Little Mermaid the
1989 film was a retelling of a classic
fairy tale but with a much happier
ending at the beginning of the movie we
meet Prince Erik then we go under the
sea to meet King Triton he's upset that
his daughter Ariel is nowhere to be
found
Ariel is excavating a shipwreck with her
fish friend flounder she's obsessed with
all things human and she desperately
wants to be one she wants to walk on
ground with feet and see new things
King Triton forbids his kingdom from
going to the surface and he sends
Sebastian the crab to watch over Ariel
Ariel has a whole secret collection of
human artifacts she wants nothing more
than to visit their world she is
obsessed AF she then sees Prince Erik
and falls in love at first sight when
Erik is thrown into the water by a storm
Ariel saves him and returns him to shore
he catches a glimpse of her but is
determined to find her Sebastian tries
to convince Ariel that staying under the
sea is better but it's no use
Ursula the sea witch has been spying on
Ariel and she wants to collect Ariel for
her collection of dreamers
when Triton finds out that Ariel is in
love with Erik he destroys all of her
human artifacts Ariel runs away and
comes across Ursula Ursula grants
Ariel's wish of becoming human but it's
an evil deal
Arielle has three days to get kissed by
Prince Eric to stay human if she doesn't
get kissed she'll belong to Ursula
forever
plus she steals Ariel's voice and leaves
her mute trapping her voice in a
necklace seriously never make a deal
with an evil sea witch Ariel unable to
speak finds herself on land she covers
herself in a sail and Eric finds her he
takes her to his palace Eric starts
falling in love with this strange girl
who cannot speak Ariel is in love with
him and she loves the human world
Ursula does not want Ariel to succeed in
kissing Eric
so she disguises herself as a beautiful
human named Vanessa she uses Ariel's
trapped voice to hypnotize Eric and they
begin to plan a wedding a bunch of sea
creatures stop the wedding and Ariel
regains her voice but before Eric can
kiss her she turns back into a mermaid
and disappears with Ursula Eric goes
after her and there's a big battle
Ursula is defeated and Triton realizes
that Ariel really will be happier as a
human he transforms her back into a
human and she and Prince Eric live
happily ever after
the fan theory at first glance you
wouldn't think Moana and the little
mermaid have much in common right
besides taking place on the sea they
seem to be very different movies the
tumblr user intergalactic ashkenazi made
a post that is really interesting he
suggests that Moana is just the story of
the little mermaid but backwards sounds
crazy right well just hear us out first
of all the little mermaid is about a sea
princess who wants to go to land Moana
is about a land princess
well Chiefs daughter who wants to go to
the sea in the Little Mermaid the big
scary ocean lady is the enemy but in
Moana the big scary ocean lady is good
Ursula traps
Ariel's voice in a magical necklace so
the story features a magical necklace
used for evil Moe Ana's grandmother
gives Moana tip feeties heart inside of
a necklace so the movie has a magical
necklace used for good in the Little
Mermaid there's a small good crab named
Sebastian in mulana there's a crab too
but Tama Toa is a giant evil crab the
sacked opposite of Sebastian speaking of
the crabs tumblr user Rosen likes books
added onto the original theory and a new
note he points out that in the Little
Mermaid a man sings about eating a crab
but in moaña a crab sings about eating a
man that's crazy there might be
something to this theory after all the
similarities in Reverse don't end there
another note by caster Luna Nova adds on
to the fan theory Ariel sinks about
enjoying life with new people and
wanting to join them at the beginning of
Moana she and the villagers sing about
enjoying life with their people and
staying put both Ariel in Moana are
destined to rule their kingdoms and
neither of them are very happy about
this idea
Ariel removes herself from the sea and
goes far away so she won't rule Moana
embraces her destiny and instead takes
her kingdom far away to explore more and
more of the sea finally in the Little
Mermaid Ariel sings on a rock in Moana a
rock sings to her that is one compelling
fan theory don't you think but was this
deliberately done by Disney we think
Disney at least partially recognized the
parallels in the Moana post-credit scene
there is a direct mention of the Little
Mermaid we see the giant evil crab Tama
Toa is still left on his back he wonders
that people would care for him more if
he was a Jamaican crab named Sebastian
it was so funny Moana is the Lord of the
Rings not everyone agrees that Moana is
basically The Little Mermaid backwards
tumblr user bouncing bumbles pointed out
that there are a ton of similarities
between Moana and the Lord of the Rings
trilogy in case you aren't familiar with
the Lord of the Rings here's a quick
overview an evil monster named Sauron
forged a ring of power but he lost it he
ends up in the hands of Frodo a hobbit
who just wants a quiet life the ring is
evil and it has to be destroyed
but lots of good people including Sauron
wants it
Frodo goes on a journey to destroy the
ring in Mount Doom he goes with three
other hobbits two men and elf and a
dwarf and a wizard in the first movie
they all get separated a massive war
breaks out and all the characters have
different roles to play
Frodo successfully destroys the
bringing peace to the land of the
middle-earth there are three movies that
came out in the early 2000s but they're
based on three books by JRR tolkien from
the mid 1900s the fan theory that
mallanna and the Lord of the Rings are
the same starts like this there's a
small but powerful token in Moana it's
the heart of toothy T in Lord of the
Rings it's the rain both of these tokens
were taken by a powerful hero who didn't
know what they were in for and they are
defeated losing these tokens to the
water these heroes are Maui and Isildur
two eccentric old people find these
tokens and it gives them a very long
life this is mo Ana's grandmother and
Frodo's uncle Bilbo they pass it on to
their younger relatives and their health
immediately fails Frodo and Moana both
have dark hair and dyes and they both
wear their special token on a necklace
they both try to get someone else to
take on the responsibility but they
discover it they have to do the quest
themselves they encounter a ton of
dangers and their final battle is at a
powerful volcano in moaña this is
takeoff in Lord of the Rings
it's Mount Doom they return their tokens
to their source the ring was made in
Mount Doom and tiffy T gets her heart
back giant birds come to save the day
Maui transforms into a giant eagle and
the giant Eagles save Frodo from Mount
Doom there's a big dramatic Tower and
both movies end with a tiny boat sailing
into the sunset Moana takes our people
to explore the sea and Frodo goes to the
undying lands with the elves basically
this fan theory suggests that Moana is
the Lord of the Rings without the real
deep evil and way less violence and it's
way funnier than the epic fantasy film -
which theory is correct
both of these tumblr users make some
really great points we aren't sure we
can imagine the creators of Moana
sitting around trying to turn the Lord
of the Rings into a Disney movie but the
parallels between the two films are
insane now the theory that Moana is
basically a reverse Little Mermaid might
be more realistic Disney Princess movies
especially the ones before the 1900s get
a lot of criticism movies like The
Little Mermaid often depict their
princesses as just wanting a man to
marry and live happily ever after in the
90s this changed a bit with
on these princesses were able to fight
their own battles and save their people
but they still had love stories the more
modern Disney movies really try to
portray these heroines as strong
independent young women I could watch
that all day okay enjoy the island brave
was the first Disney princess movie with
no love story at all in frozen Anna may
have found love but Queen Elsa didn't
and wanna add way better things to do
than fall in love and get married
anyways do you think Moana is the
reverse story of the Little Mermaid
don't be shy come let us know in the
comments below and that's it for this
wild fan theory that Moana is just the
little mermaid backwards give this video
a big thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe see you later
[Music]